well meanwhile the U.S President Joe
Biden has been criticized by the U.N
Secretary General rights groups and some
fellow democrats for his decision to
supply cluster bombs to Ukraine they are
banned by more than 120 countries but
not the U.S Russia or Ukraine the White
House says it's aware of the risks to
civilians but it couldn't leave
Ukrainian troops defenseless the latest
to criticize the move has been the U.S
Ally UK prime minister Rishi sunak let's
go to our White House correspondent
Kimberly Hockett who's live for us now
Kimberly so talk us through exactly the
reaction back home in the U.S to
President Biden's move
well it's not sitting well with some
members of the president's own
Democratic party specifically the
progressive Wing or the further left
wing of the democratic party you have to
remember that when the president came
into office he said that the foundation
of his foreign policy was going to be
human rights this would be the sort of
the Forefront of making all of his
foreign policy decisions and so that is
why they are upset because this is a
decision that seems completely opposite
of that and so what we've had is 19
members of the progressive wing of the
democratic party signing a letter
sending it to President Biden sharply
criticizing him saying that that cluster
Munitions are the exact wrong choice
because of the indiscriminate harm that
they will cause to those civilians that
will be around long after the conflict
ends what they say is there's no such
thing as a safe cluster bomb and that
it's not consistent with President
Biden's promise to be a leader when he
promised to really have the United
States be a leader when it comes to
Human Rights around the world no indeed
and there is an element of hypocrisy
here isn't there I mean the US is in the
past criticized Russia for example for
using cluster bombs in Syria now it's uh
giving them to Ukraine
yeah that's right in fact uh very early
on in this conflict the White House
Press Secretary was asked about the use
of Russia using cluster bombs and what
the response was was if that were true
it would be considered a war crime we
also know that Linda Thomas Greenfield
when she was speaking earlier last year
rather at the United Nations General
Assembly taught generally about the use
of cluster Munitions saying that when
they were used generally speaking that
they are banned under the Geneva
conventions and also the fact that when
they're used there really is no place
for them on the battlefield because of
the disproportionate harm they caused to
civilians so the fact that now this
administration of which they both work
for has decided to use them as part of a
package given to Ukraine this latest
weapons package to the tune of 800
million is really being sharply
criticized around the world as being
absolute hypocrisy but the defense that
is being given by the National Security
advisor is a really ethical hair
splitting by all accounts according to
the critics it the argument being made
is look at Russia's already used it
they're already on the battlefield the
they're already being littered with
these bomblets if you will so it's
already going to have to be demined so
what's the harm if Ukraine is already
going to use it in the same space but
obviously that is not sitting well with
the International Community
thank you for that Kimberly Honker our
White House correspondent